نبدا بهشام الهدوء الذي كنا نتحدث عنه
ونشير اليه مازال متواصلا
بالفعل محمد هو الهدوء الان مرت ساعتين من
هذا الهدوء الحذر الذي يكسره فقط اصوات
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه التي تحلق
ما بين الفينه والاخرى وتنفذ طلعات في
سماء القطاع وايضا يكسره اصوات طائرات
الاستطلاع الاسرائيليه المعروفه هنا باسم
الزنانه التي تحلق على مدار اليوم وطوال
في ايام الاسبوع
وتراقب عن كثب ما يجري في القطاع وكافه
التتار التحركات على الارض وفي الميدان
سواء كانت هذه للمواطنين ام حتى للمقاومين
الفلسطينيين جميع التحركات في قطاع غزه هي
مراقبه ومرصوده من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي
من خلال عده تقنيات من بينها هذه الطائرات
اذا هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه ورغم هذا
الهدوء الحذر الذي يسود القطاع هي تواصلت
قبل عده ساعات قبل ساعتين من الان اخر
غاره كانت في خان يونس جنوب اقطاع غزه
واستهدفت ارضا زراعيه في تلك المنطقه وكان
هناك ايضا خلال هذا اليوم العديد من
الغارات الاسرائيليه على عده اهداف سواء
كانت منازل وشقق سكنيه وكان هناك قصف لشقه
سكنيه لشقه سكنيه في حي الزيتون في جنوب
مدينه غزه وايضا كان هناك الحدث الابرز في
هذا اليوم وهو عمليه الاغتيال التي نفذتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه بحق اياد
الحسن احد القاده البارزين في سرايا القدس
وهو عضو مجلسها العسكري عندما استهدفت في
حي النصر في غرب وفي شمال مدينه غزه عندما
استهدفت شقه سكنيه في تلك المنطقه ودمرتها
وقتلت الحسني وايضا ومرافقا له وبالتالي
الغارات الاسرائيليه وخلال الايام الماضيه
تاخذ منحنيات مختلفه ما بين متسارعه وهدوء
في بعض الاحيان وهذا الهدوء الحذر في
الكثير من المرات وبحسب الكثير كما رصدنا
من المرات كان هناك هذا الهدوء يسبق
عمليات اغتيال لا سيما وان جميع عمليات
الاغتيال سبقها هدوء في صباح هذا اليوم
كان هدوءا استمر لعده ساعات وبعد ذلك اشتد
اشتدت حده القصف الاسرائيلي على مناطق
مختلفه من القطاع واغتالت بعدها اسرائيل
قائد بارز في سرايا القدس وبالامس كذلك
كان هناك عده اغتيالات كان هناك اغتيالين
من لقائدين بارزين في سرايا القدس وكان
سبق ذلك ساعات من الهدوء لذلك هذا الهدوء
يفسر على عده اتجاهات اما باتجاه انه ان
هناك تصعيد قادم ربما هناك عمليات رصد
للجيش الاسرائيلي لتحركات معينه للمقاومين
او تحركات معينه في غزه او ربما يرصد على
انه هناك محاوله لاعطاء فرصه للمباحثات
التي تجري في القاهره لكن هذه المباحثات
التي تجري وهناك اتصالات عده لهؤلاء
الوسطاء ربما ردت عليهم الغرفه المشتركه
لفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي اصدرت
بيانا قبل قليل وتحدثت فيه ونعت اياد
الحسني هذا القائد في المقاومه الفلسطينيه
لكن الابرز في هذا الموضوع عندما قالت ان
قتالنا مستمر وسنواصل التزامنا امام دماء
الشهداء مهما كلف ذلك من ثمن وهذه
بالتاكيد نقراها كانها رساله لانها جاءت
بعد يعني عده انباء من الطرف الاسرائيلي
عن ان الساعه الثانيه عشره من منتصف هذا
الليل يمكن ان يكون هناك تهدئه انسانيه
وبالتالي الفصائل الفلسطينيه ترفض ترفض كل
هذه الانباء وتؤكد بحسب العديد من المصادر
ان اسرائيلي يجب ان تتراجع عن قضيه
الاغتيالات وهذا الشرط الاساسي الذي تقف
عنده كل هذه المباحثات